oh what a sh there are actually normal
people in New York welcome to Hannity
we're back with a live studio audience a
few normal New Yorkers shocking they
haven't gone to Florida yet anyway
all right tonight we begin with good
news your Fearless vice president Kamala
Harris is back from Europe and she's
feeling very inspired we're going to
play her Visionary remarks they're
coming up straight ahead also the latest
Republicans who join the 2024 races on a
mission to abolish affirmative action
and Destroy woke culture uh Vivek Rama
Swami I don't know if you know who he is
he is going to join us he's made quite a
splash lately so we'll introduce you to
him uh first three weeks now after the
disaster in East Palestine in Ohio and
one day after a visit from former
president Donald Trump Americas right he
was the first one to go America's under
qualified Transportation secretary
pothole Pete finally made a trip over to
Ohio but he was definitely not thrilled
to be there as he looked miserable the
entire time he was dodging and ducking
questions all day refused to take any
responsibility for anything in fact uh
he all but blamed a vast right-wing
conspiracy for his bad press that he's
been receiving even faulting the Trump
Administration for the train wreck and
according to pothole Pete his only
mistake was he didn't tweet about the
crisis sooner uh maybe the maybe you
should have been dealing with the crisis
and a chemical burn that was killing
fish and wildlife and injuring human
beings that would have been the smart
thing to do now apparently America's
current Transportation secretary is
clearly not responsible for America's
Transportation take a look
uh the American public doesn't seem to
be very confident in your ability to do
your job will you be resigning anytime
soon I'm not here for politics I'm here
to make sure the community can get what
they need will you apologize
for the response for the slow response
taking your time
you know what I tried to do was balance
two things my desire to be involved and
engaged and on the ground which is uh
how I am uh generally wired to act and
my desire to follow the norm of
Transportation secretaries
follow the norm don't show up and don't
care is that the norm now other than
deflecting criticism pothole Pete didn't
have much to offer meanwhile his very
own press secretary was even less
forthcoming with information actually
she was demanding that members of the
press turn off their cameras before they
would ask any questions take a look at
this
I would like you guys to turn your
cameras off you're not on my camera well
I'm on a camera I would like your camera
to be off and I'm happy to talk to you
guys well if you as a press secretary of
the secretary of the Department of
Transportation don't you think you
should be able to ask questions from the
American public that absolutely I would
like to do it without the camera on can
I ask well I think that is a little bit
aggressive can I ask what the secretary
is going to do with the picture of Jenny
care he took her the other day
I'm happy to answer your questions I
would like you guys to not have your
cameras on I think my camera the minute
ago if I turn it off with you I'll have
your cameras on and I can see them from
the most transparent Administration they
promised in history okay let's get this
straight the Biden Administration
totally ignored what was the controlled
toxic chemical burn in East Palestine
for weeks they look the other way as
local fish and animals were dying they
didn't seem to care that people were
getting sick or that streams and Creeks
had a metallic Sheen to them they even
refused to deploy FEMA assistance until
they were came into doing so and by the
way just like mayor Pete was shamed into
showing up a day late and a dollar short
after Donald Trump had gone there the
day before only to tell locals that it's
not his fault and the media to turn off
the cameras because they didn't want to
be caught on camera saying what they
really think and they didn't have
answers to the questions anyway that is
a slap in the face to the American
people but meanwhile Joe Biden was over
in Ukraine offering another half a
billion dollars of your money uh to the
effort in Ukraine while we're paying
more than three times what the rest of
Europe is paying to help zielinski now
from potholes to train wrecks mayor Pete
like most of the Biden Administration
they've kind of failed their way up if
you will in the worst possible way now
if he had any honor any decency he would
resign if Joe Biden wanted somebody
competent it's not mayor Pete they
should let somebody that is competent
run the Department of Transportation
sadly that won't happen and and pothole
Pete feels entitled to this very
important job and we see what happens
when you don't have the right person
leading the way by the way he could care
less about the people of East Palestine
I know it you know it the rest of East
Palestine knows it and by the way we do
not have any clue what the long-term
impacts will be anyway our own Sarah
Carter she has been on the ground from
the very beginning investigative
reporter she was there earlier take a
look
was it kind of frustrating that the
Secretary of Transportation Pete Buda
judge came down but he he came at eight
o'clock in the morning did you even have
an opportunity to see him or or ask him
a question
um no he came after Trump came in and I
would like to keep keep this not
political
um but I feel like that's the only
reason he showed up is for political
purposes how did you feel today about
um secretary Buda judge's visit and
considering it's been three weeks since
the he actually was not here for it but
I think that they have not done enough
for us not the people in this town
deserve a lot better it goes through
your mind when when something like that
occurs like when you just realize it's
been oh it's been three weeks since the
incident now someone shows up
it's it's very discouraging because you
really want someone to be able to come
down and even though we're a very small
town or a village now it it makes you
feel like we're not worth anything to
anybody so Pete Buda judge shows up this
morning very early who is people to
judge
really seriously
do you see him as the secretary glad he
was here on his
not his private time
because yesterday he was on his private
time and couldn't be interviewed all
right that was great who's people to
judge anyway I seriously doubt that uh
Pete will return to East Palestine every
anytime soon and it is very unlikely his
boss Joe Biden will ever make the trip
uh middle class Joe doesn't seem to give
a rip about the middle class never has
never will and by the way it's not in
Delaware he rarely leaves Delaware hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else